نبقى في بريطانيا والى نتفليكس التي طرحت
ذكراون وهو المسلسل الخامس لكنه الاول بعد
وفاه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه واعتلاء
الملك تشارلز الثالث عرش بريطانيا يتميز
الموسم الجديد لمشاركه ممثلين عرب هما
سليم ضوء في دور محمد الفايد وخالد عبد
الله في دور دودي الفايد حبيب الاميره
ديانا الذي لقي مصرعه معها في حادث في
باريس عام سبعه 97 ومن بريطانيا معروف تاج
الدين
[موسيقى]
ظروف مختلفه تحيط باطلاق الموسم الخامس
لمسلسل ذكريون الانجليزيه هذا العام فهو
الاول ومنذ وفاه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
والاول منذ اعتلاء الملك تشارلز العرش
البريطاني ما يعني انا دورت دومني كويس
ياتي في وقت حساس بالنسبه لملك ما زال
يستقر في منصبه ويحاوله كسب قلوب
بريطانيين
ومن المتوقع ان يجذب الموسم قاعده
جماهيريه عربيه حيث يضم طاقم التمثيل هذا
العام ممثلين عربا لتشديد دور محمد الفايد
وابنه دود الفايد
[موسيقى]
يعني
نقوم باداء هذه الشخصيات العملاقه كان في
مشاهد احنا
بنصورها واحنا احنا احنا بقينا المشاهدين
العرب بنتفرج يا لهوي ده احنا بنعمل ده في
حاجه جميله
نافع عند السعاده
الفتره المطربه من حياه الاميره ديانا
والمقابله التي صعقد العالم وزعزعت العرش
البريطاني عام
1995 قبل عامين من وفاتها الماء سوريه
ويواجه المسلسل عاصفه من الانتقادات من
قبل الوسطين الفني والسياسي التي تتهم
القائمين عليه
خلال مرحله صعبه
لعائله الملكيه حيث يكشف المسلسل ان
الامير تشارلز حاول اقناع الملكه بالتنازل
عن العرش كما يتم ترشيد المشاكل بين
تشارلز وزوجته انا ذاك الاميره ديانا بشكل
يعتبره البعض انه يصور الملك
لايك شادي
من احداث المسلسل وما قد يحدثه من سطر يقع
ذا كراون من اعلى المسلسلات مشاهده فيما
لا تزال العائله الملكيه تشكل ماده دسمه
تثير فضول العالم سواء كان ذلك في الواقع
او على الشاشه العربيه
الموسم الخامس من ذكرهم ربما يكون الاكثر
جدلا منذ بدايه عرض العمل في 2016
الانتقادات تركز على ان خيال المؤلف ثم
فرضه على انه واقع المسلسل عصرناها بالفعل
وان كانت هناك بعض التوابل لاضافه نكهه
ثانوي
ليس وثائقيا
يتناول موسم جديد فتره التسعينات وهو
العقد الاكثر حساسيه في تاريخ العائله
الملكه العقد الذي كتب نهايه
لثلاث جيجات وشهد حريق عام 1992 وحدث
القرن مقتل ديانا
بعد وفاه الملكه اصبح اي تصوير سلبي
لابنها تشارلز اكثر دقه لان ذلك يعني
انتقاد الملك الحالي بسوره المباشره واحد
الامثله عرض المكالمه الحميميه المسربه
بين تشارلز وكامله نقد اخر كان بطلها
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق الذي وصف
مشهد محادثته مع ملكه تشارلز وتدبيره
للاطاحه بالملكه
اثار الجدل
مقربه من العائله المالكه على انها كانت
مجرد صديقه لي